- Comedy and media matters.
And there's no way that you can say
that it doesn't matter.
And it affects things.
So I know that it has an impact,
but at the same time,
just because you can find a person
who is truly and genuinely
offended by what you say,
does that make it wrong?
You know what I mean?
'Cause then at what point
can you say anything?
(upbeat music)
- Hey all, welcome to another
episode of Is This Okay?
Where we talk about things
and ask the question,
is this really okay?
Today we are discussing when is something
considered offensive versus funny,
and how do you personally draw that line.
- I do believe that PC is
killing comedy in a way,
because I feel like jokes should be,
they should kind of
strike you and be funny.
- They invite conflict 100 percent.
That's just the personality
that goes into it.
And they just write jokes
to get people to react.
- So my whole thing about like, being PC,
and like oh, you need to not offend people
and you need to try your
best not hurt people.
I don't think that's too
much to ask of comedians.
- As a comedic person, you
realize there's a lot of grey.
You might get to a
point where you're like,
you know what, I'm always
gonna offend somebody.
And then because of that,
you then just go, fuck it.
And I do think that there
is still something honorable
about at least trying to navigate it.
You try and be sensitive,
but you also know
you can't please everybody.
But wait, what was the one you had?
What was the example
that you had thought of?
- So, yeah, this is where I draw my line.
Amy Poehler is the executive
producer of Difficult People.
- I love that show.
- Yeah, I don't watch it, but.
There was a joke on the show.
Julie, the main character,
tweeted something
along the lines of like, I can't wait
for R. Kelly to piss on Blue Ivy.
Like, until Blue Ivy is older enough
so R. Kelly can piss on her.
And, she was kind of like,
you know I did this mean tweet
but I don't understand why
everyone's so mad at me?
- Yeah, the context of the...
(laughter)
- I love that you're
laughing about it right now.
- It's like you though
it was funny! Garrick!
- The context of the joke is that,
is that, not, you're
looking at the wrong person.
I think you're looking at Blue Ivy,
and you're like, oh I hear this
word, I think of an infant.
You should be looking at R.
Kelly who peed on a person.
- Well yeah, I'm looking at it both sides.
Yeah, it's like exploitation.
- It's exploitation of...
It's R. Kelly who is, I mean,
arguably a bad dude that
pisses on minors, and-
- Yeah, I'd argue that.
(laughter)
- But yeah he does.
- He's a bad dude, he made a bad call.
- And I think if I was Beyonce,
and that was my daughter,
they made a joke about
peeing on my daughter,
I'd be hella pissed.
- I was offended because I love Beyonce.
- I love Beyonce!
- And I love Blue.
- I think a lot of really great comics,
the way that they subvert
PC culture is making it
that much clearer that this is my opinion,
and I do not take myself seriously,
none of them takes themselves seriously.
- Don't you think it's tough though?
Because I have a hard time
listening to a comedian
and he makes a really smart,
witty, social commentary
comment and I can't lie that
so much of why I like it
is because I'm like "God,
that's such a good point."
So I can't give you that
love, then the next thing
you say be "Oh but
nothing he says matters".
- You're a problematic
person in your everyday life,
then I don't know if I can
really support you as a comedian.
- I love offensive jokes,
I watch Margaret Cho
and I watch Kathy Griffin,
they both have really offensive jokes,
but they're done in a way
that is a lot more smart
and it actually says
something about our society.
- I think if you're going
to make fun of something
that is sensitive, it
should be really witty,
and be like "That's kind of offensive,
but it was so creative and so well worded.
That was funny."
- So is it basically for you, if it's,
as long as it's funny it's not offensive?
- No, cause there are
some things that, like,
Eddie Murphy, comic, comedic icon,
opens up his acts bashing
gay people, essentially,
and I'm like woah, like
for me watching it,
it was extremely hurtful.
- It feels harsh, I'm like
eh, maybe he shouldn't be,
we wouldn't be saying
these things to this day.
- And it depends on who's
saying the joke too.
Like a Latino person talking
about the Latino experience
and kind of making fun of our
culture and making it funny,
you're like that's funny, that's cool.
- You just have to, I
mean if it's coming from,
even if it was coming from, like,
if I heard a black joke from a white guy.
- That would make you
more mad, it'd have to.
- It'd kind of, but if he...
(laughter)
Come on, if he presents himself-
- If I got on a mic and
started talking about
the funny things about black
people, you wouldn't be like
"Wow this is the exact
same reaction I would have
if a black man were up there."
- No it's not the same.
- Yeah, he would not!
- I'd take my earrings off, like.
- All the minorities would
be like "Whatchu sayin'?"
- All four of you would kill me.
- Right, you know you need to, like,
sit the fuck down, or whatever.
But at the same time,
if you come at a place
where it is like, I feel
like you are with me
instead of against me.
- Ally Wang and Bill Burr
are like two of my favorites.
I know for example when Bill
Burr says something funny,
how I can listen to
him say the same jokes,
and one night I'm like "I
didn't feel like you enough
hatred coming behind that"
and other times I'm like
"I feel like there was a
lot of hatred behind that."
- I just hope that I don't
feel like I wasted my money.
I just want to laugh,
I just want to laugh!
- People are learning from
each other every day, right?
And it's a dialogue that
we're just have to be open
with each other, just learn.
- I understand that it's
grey, but I always lean on
can I feel what your real intent is.
If I can feel your real
intent is not malicious,
it matters a lot to me.
- To be fair though, in certain times,
intent does not matter
if it hurts somebody,
because people's hurt feelings are valid.
- How about you?
- A joke is a joke is a joke.
(laughter)
Just write good ones, you know?
A lot of the times, the better the joke,
the more you'll get away with.
I'm just a big fan of jokes.
- Okay guys, so when does
comedy become too offensive?
Leave your comments below,
and we'll see you next week.
- Your answer sounded so
much cooler than mine.
(laughter)
- All, like, poetic, "a joke is a joke".